Salut les épicurieuses
et les épicurieux !
Dès qu'on parle de voitures, on est tous
convaincus d'être d'excellents conducteurs
ou conductrices.
On a tendance à surestimer nos capacités
et à l'inverse à sous-estimer les imprévus
et les dangers qui peuvent
survenir sur la route.
J'ai rendez-vous dans un centre d'essai pour
un petit stage de conduite.
Allez, en piste ! Tout le monde va en profiter.
Thibault, on commence par quoi ?
Du freinage d'urgence.
À quelle vitesse va rouler le véhicule ?
À 30 km/h.
C'est très peu 30 km/h.
C'est très peu, mais on va s'apercevoir que
c'est vraiment beaucoup dès qu'on va être
dans une zone où on croise beaucoup d'autres
formes de mobilité et notamment toutes les
personnes qui sont pas protégées par une
carrosserie et pour nous aider on va simuler,
grâce à ces quatre cônes bleus, l'endroit
où on veut déclencher notre freinage d'urgence.
C'est-à-dire qu'au moment où le nez de la
voiture va arriver au niveau de ces plots,
j'écrase le frein ?
Vulgairement, tu piles.
Tu peux y aller.
Voilà, on y est.
Tu es prêt ? On écrase le frein.
J'ai fait ce que tu m'as dit ! Allons mesurer !
Distance de freinage assez courte.
Tu t'attendais à quoi ? Je sais pas trop
en fait, mais ça me donne déjà un ordre
d'idée.
Ouais là je suis à 2,5 mètres,
à 1 ou 2 cm près.
On va mettre notre repère, ce cône blanc
à l'endroit où on s'est arrêté à 30 km/h.
D'accord, si on met un repère, ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas fini l'exercice.
Continuons soyons joueurs !
Si on doublait la vitesse ?
60 km/h.
J'imagine qu'intuitivement, la plupart des
personnes se disent : on va deux fois plus
vite, on va aller deux fois plus loin.
Par expérience, effectivement, c'est la pensée
pratiquement de monsieur tout le monde.
Prêt ? On y est bientôt, regarde au loin.
Top !
Super ! Tu as vu, c'est dur psychologiquement.
Je suis très très loin de l'endroit où
j'avais mis les plots.
Je rappelle qu'initialement, lorsque je roulais
à 30 km/h, il m'a fallu 2 mètres 50 pour
m'arrêter, qu'en roulant à 60 km/h intuitivement
on se dit il faut deux fois plus de distance
donc 5 mètres.
Dans la réalité, voilà où on s'est arrêté.
12 mètres.
Plus de 4 fois plus.
On va reprendre les données du problème.
Pour s'arrêter, une voiture doit évacuer
toute l'énergie cinétique qu'elle a emmagasinée,
c'est-à-dire l'énergie qui est liée à
son mouvement.
Cette énergie cinétique est égale à la
moitié de la masse du véhicule, multipliée
par la vitesse au carré.
À 30 km/h, on multiplie donc
30 par 30 : par 900.
Dans ces conditions, la distance de freinage
nécessaire pour évacuer l'énergie cinétique
emmagasinée par le véhicule que je conduisais
est d'environ 3 mètres.
À 60 km/h maintenant, cette énergie est
égale à la moitié de la masse de mon véhicule
toujours, multipliée par 60 au carré autrement
dit multipliée par 3600, c'est 4 fois plus.
Voilà pourquoi il m'a fallu, à 60 km/h,
12 mètres pour m'arrêter.
Par conséquent, quand la vitesse est multipliée
par deux, la distance de freinage est multipliée
par 4.
D'où l'importance de respecter la limitation
de vitesse : même un petit excès peut engendrer
de graves conséquences.
Et c'est parti, même chose que tout à l'heure.
Même chose, essaie d'accélérer vraiment
assez tôt pour vraiment arriver à une vitesse
stabilisée comme ça on se concentre sur
le top.
Continue.
Top !
OK.
Allons mesurer.
Ah oui, on s'est arrêté bien avant.
Mesurons ! On revient à 50, je suis à 8.
4 mètres de différence.
Cette distance te paraît pas familière en
ville ?
Si, c'est la largeur d'un passage piéton.
Ce qui veut dire que là où je me trouve,
à l'entrée du passage piéton, avec ta voiture
à 60 km/h, tu roules encore à
au moins 30 km/h.
On voit donc que 10 km/h d'excès en ville
- 60 au lieu de 50 - c'est extrêmement dangereux
pour les piétons.
En effet, cela nécessite la largeur d'un
passage piéton en plus pour que le véhicule
s'arrête.
D'ailleurs, pour être parfaitement juste,
la distance de freinage n'est pas le seul
paramètre à prendre en compte pour l'arrêt
du véhicule.
Il faut ajouter la distance liée au temps
de réaction.
Voilà un appareil qui permet de mesurer le
temps de réaction.
Alors comment vais-je pouvoir connaître mon
temps de réaction ?
On a reproduit une situation de conduite grâce
à un capteur qui est au sol qui représente
ta pédale de frein.
On va commencer par le mode le plus facile,
donc le temps de réaction simple.
Tu vas freiner quand le voyant rouge s'allume.
Tu vas mettre le pied, dans un premier temps,
à droite de la pédale pour simuler que tu
as ton pied sur l'accélérateur.
C'est parti !
Tu vas pouvoir relâcher et là on s'aperçoit que tu as
0.47 seconde de temps de réaction.
Presque une demi-seconde.
Alors c'est pas beaucoup, mais pendant ce
temps-là, la voiture se déplace et là quelle
distance a-t-elle parcourue ? A 50 km/h, pendant
ces 0,47 seconde, tu as parcouru 7 mètres.
Tu as dit que c'était le cas le plus simple,
un cas un peu plus compliqué.
Cette fois, je vais pas te demander simplement
d'appuyer sur le frein à l'allumage d'une
lumière rouge, mais à l'allumage d'un symbole
inconnu.
Qu'est-ce que ça change, le fait que ce soit
un symbole inconnu ? L'analyse qu'on va demander
à ton cerveau.
Ca va s'approcher d'une situation plus réelle
de conduite.
Tu vas devoir freiner à ce symbole.
On peut lancer.
Dis-moi Jamy, tu saurais m'épeler "épicurieux"
à l'envers ?
(rires) Epicurieux à l'envers...
Alors c'est x,
Ah, malin ! Alors là, mon temps était beaucoup
plus élevé, j'ai fait plus d'une seconde.
J'étais concentré sur le signal, mais en
plus tu me parlais, je réfléchissais en
même temps.
Il m'a fallu plus de temps pour réagir tout
simplement, pour réagir.
Tout à l'heure, mon temps de réaction était
de 0,47 seconde me semble-t-il et la distance
parcourue pendant ce laps de temps était
de 7 mètres.
Là qu'est-ce que ça donne pour
1,01 seconde ? 14 mètres.
Deux fois plus.
Quand un obstacle surgit sur la route ou qu'un
événement imprévu se produit, on ne peut
pas réagir instantanément, on l'a vu, c'est
impossible.
1) Les images captées par les yeux sont d'abord
transmises au cerveau,
2) celui-ci analyse les données et 3) si
la situation est jugée trop dangereuse, le
cerveau commande au pied d'appuyer sur la
pédale de frein.
Seulement, le temps que ce processus aboutisse,
il s'écoule entre une demi-seconde, si l'on
est attentif, à 2 si on l'est moins.
Temps pendant lequel le véhicule continue
à avancer.
Pour déterminer la distance nécessaire à
un véhicule pour s'arrêter, il faut donc
ajouter à la distance de freinage la distance
parcourue pendant le temps de réaction.
A 30 km/h, ce véhicule parcourt 9 mètres
en une seconde.
Pour s'arrêter, il aura donc besoin de 9
mètres, distance parcourue pendant le temps
de réaction : une seconde, auquel il faut
ajouter 3 mètres : distance de freinage,
soit un total de 12 mètres.
A 60 km/h le véhicule parcourt maintenant
18 mètres en une seconde.
Pour s'immobiliser, il aura donc besoin de
18 mètres, distance parcourue pendant le
temps de réaction, auquel on ajoute 12 mètres,
distance de freinage, soit un total de
30 mètres pour s'immobiliser.
Quels conseils peut-on donner aux automobilistes
pour réduire cette distance liée au temps
de réaction ?
Bien sûr, baisser la vitesse, mais est-ce
qu'il y a autre chose ?
Tu vas pouvoir appliquer une seule technique :
ce qu'on appelle le pied au frein.
Dès que tu vas pressentir une situation à
risque, tu vas pas laisser ton pied droit
sur l'accélérateur, mais tu vas déjà le
préparer juste devant la pédale.
Ce petit geste anodin va avoir un effet très
important.
On va le refaire en mode facile pour comparer
avec la première donnée.
Je suis prêt.
A l'allumage de la lumière rouge qui était,
pour rappel, à 0 47.
C'est ça.
C'est parti.
0,28.
Ah oui j'ai gagné quand-même 20 centièmes
de seconde.
Ca paraît rien dans la vie 20 centièmes,
voyons voir ce que ça nous apporte en mètres.
Je suis passé de 7 mètres à 4 mètres.
3 mètres ça peut sauver une vie.
C'est pratiquement un passage piéton.
Le temps de réaction ne dépend pas que de
notre vitesse, il dépend aussi de notre attention
et des distractions qu'on peut avoir au volant.
Dans notre monde hyperconnecté, difficile
de s'en passer.
Près de 80% des conducteurs français avouent
l'utiliser au volant.
Pire : 34% avouent lire ou écrire des SMS.
24% consulter leurs notifications.
8%, publier des stories sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tout cela peut avoir de graves conséquences.
OK Jamy, je te propose une nouvelle situation.
Je vais te demander d'envoyer un sms.
En conduisant ? C'est interdit ! C'est interdit,
mais c'est pour ça qu'on le fait au cœur
d'un centre d'essai sur une route fermée
à la circulation.
OK et qu'est-ce que j'envoie comme message ?
Et ben on va envoyer l'adresse à Manu de
la fête de ce soir.
C'est 24 rue de la Glacière.
Alors, les chiffres d'abord.
24... rue de la Glacière
Tu me dis si y'a quelqu'un en face.
J'espère qu'il y en aura aucun.
Glacière, Paris 13.
Surtout là j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait personne
en face.
C'est parti.
Bon alors, qu'est-ce que ça a donné ? Heureusement
qu'il y avait personne en face parce que je
pense qu'on serait pas bien à cette heure-ci !
Ah bon ? Parce que moi j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression de rester dans l'axe.
T'as quand même pas mal quitté les yeux
de la route.
D'après une étude américaine, écrire un
SMS au volant multiplie par 23 le risque d'accident.
Il faut dire que rien que la lecture d'un
message monopolise l'attention pendant plusieurs
secondes.
Combien de temps avez-vous mis pour lire ce
sms ? 3, 4, 5 secondes ? Eh bien pendant ce
temps, nos yeux ne regardent pas la route
alors que le véhicule, lui, continue la sienne.
A 30 km/h, en 3 secondes, il parcourt 27 mètres
alors qu'il n'en fait que 9 en une seconde,
ce qui augmente considérablement la distance
d'arrêt en cas de nécessité et je ne vous
parle pas des écarts de trajectoire comme
on l'a vu dans l'expérience.
Petit rappel : utiliser son téléphone au
volant est strictement interdit par la loi,
c'est 135 euros d'amende et trois points en
moins sur le permis.
La vitesse, le téléphone, il y a un autre
facteur aggravant au volant : l'alcool.
Je te propose un nouvel exercice, cette fois
sur le thème de l'alcool au volant.
Je t'ai prévu un parcours avec des cônes.
Premier passage : tu le feras à jeun, tu
n'as pas bu, tu seras donc le Sam !
Et la deuxième fois, on va simuler ton alcoolémie
par des lunettes altérant ta vision.
En faisant le Sam, déjà tu vas commencer
par fermer la maison.
Très bien ! Je te chronomètre.
Premier virage à droite
Il n'a touché aucun cône.
Il ne reste plus que la manœuvre.
1 minute 56.
Et voilà !
Bon alors, pas trop mal ?
1 minute 56, c'est ton temps de référence.
Très bien.
Aucun cône, c'est le plus important surtout.
A voir sur la deuxième partie maintenant.
La seule différence, c'est que les lunettes
vont te perturber visuellement, te recréer
ce défaut justement visuel d'équilibre que
va nous causer l'alcool et pour bien mesurer
tes gestes, on va commencer de la même
façon : je vais te lancer les clés.
Ah bah oui, je les loupe.
Et j'ai du mal à les attraper.
Je vais même t'accompagner pour pas que tu
tombes.
Ouh là, oui, j'ai l'impression de tituber
un petit peu et maintenant je rejoins la voiture.
J'ai l'impression que le sol s'échappe sous
mes pieds.
Par sécurité cette fois, je vais peut-être
monter avec toi.
Avec plaisir !
J'aurai accès au frein à main.
Tiens ! Pas mal !
Je m'installe.
Ouh là là ! Ca va ? Pas trop envie de vomir ?
Oh c'est très bizarre ! Je vais pouvoir
lancer le chronomètre.
C'est à droite pour rappel.
Ouais, mais je ne sais pas où je suis là...
J'ai beaucoup de mal
beaucoup de mal à repérer
Ah ouais, oh là là ! Alors on imagine, dans
une petite rue, comme ça, l'état de la voiture
qui ressort toute griffée.
Je sais pas où je suis là...
J'avance.
Tu vois quand-même les cônes bleus ? Je
vois les cônes bleus.
Fixe-toi ça comme objectif.
Voilà.
Alors c'est dingue parce que je vois double
aussi ! Ce qui est caractéristique.
Ca ça peut vraiment arriver et là on mesure
le danger quand on prend le volant dans cet
état et on le mesure bien parce que là on
est conscient parce que lorsqu'on a bu, il
y a un truc en plus, c'est que on est désinhibé
donc on ne mesure pas ce danger et ça j'ai
pas de moyens de te le faire subir.
Où est-ce que je vais là ? Ce qui est dingue,
c'est que j'y vais un petit peu au pif là.
Punaise, où est-ce que je suis ?
Pour ton information, tu as déjà dépassé
ton temps de plus d'une minute.
Tu ne veux même pas me donner un tout petit
coup de main ? T'as bu tout seul, t'es grand !
Ah non, j'étais pas tout seul ! Il y en
a d'autres qui buvaient avec moi.
Je m'arrête là, c'est trop dur ! Pratiquement
deux minutes de plus ! 4min24.
Mais dans quel état je vais retrouver la
voiture ?
Bon, t'es confiant ? Ecoute, tant que j'ai
les lunettes, ça va ! Mais je redoute le
moment où je vais les retirer !
Bon après avoir compté les verres, on va
compter les dégâts !
Oh là là là !
Bon bah, je crois que t'as fait le pare-choc !
Tu peux appeler l'assurance ! D'où l'importance
de surtout ne pas boire quand on prend le
volant.
Effectivement, il y a une tolérance en France
qui est - tu la connais bien - de 0,5 g d'alcool
par litre de sang, voire 0,2 gramme par litre
de sang pour les conducteurs novices.
Et puis surtout, si on va à une soirée où
on sait qu'elle va être arrosée, eh bien
on donne les clés à celui qu'on choisit :
le Sam.
Lui, le Sam, ne consomme aucune goutte d'alcool.
On va revenir sur certaines idées reçues
concernant l'alcool.
Ca ne dépend pas de la boisson, que ce soit
un demi, un verre de vin ou un alcool fort,
ces trois boissons contiennent la même quantité
d'alcool pur.
C'est simplement la concentration qui change,
que vous ayez consommé l'une ou l'autre de
ces trois boissons, vous aurez absorbé la
même quantité d'alcool.
Autre idée reçue : on entend souvent dire
qu'en mangeant, on atténue les effets de l'alcool.
C'est faux !
Manger décale simplement le phénomène.
Le taux d'alcoolémie maximale est atteint
30 minutes après l'absorption si vous êtes
à jeun, une heure si vous avez bu au cours
d'un repas ce qui tord le cou à une autre
idée reçue selon laquelle on pourrait reprendre
le volant si on s'est arrêté de boire une
heure avant.
Il faut simplement se souvenir que l'organisme
élimine au maximum 0,15 g d'alcool par heure
et par litre de sang.
Il faut parfois une bonne nuit de sommeil
pour éliminer les excès.
Allez, une dernière pour la route : le café,
le cachet d'aspirine, pratiquer un exercice
physique intense ne fera pas descendre votre
taux d'alcoolémie.
Le plus simple - on le répète - celui qui
conduit, c'est celui qui ne boit pas !
Les voitures ne sont pas seules sur la route,
de moins en moins, surtout en ville, où les
vélos sont de plus en plus nombreux.
Du coup, les conducteurs de voiture doivent
rester extrêmement vigilants.
Ils doivent penser à mettre leur clignotant
en amont pour indiquer qu'ils changent de
direction, regarder dans les rétroviseurs
et vérifier les angles morts.
Vérifier qu'il n'y a personne au moment où
ils tournent.
Petit rappel : lorsqu'une voiture tourne à
droite, le vélo qui arrive sur le côté
est prioritaire.
Un type d'accident est de plus en plus fréquent :
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'emportiérage.
Un conducteur s'arrête sur le bas-côté
et ouvre sa portière pour sortir du véhicule
et là "bing" un cycliste, qui arrive sur le
côté, percute la portière de plein fouet.
Pour éviter ce genre d'accident, qui peut
être très grave, il existe un geste : l'ouverture
de la portière à la hollandaise.
On l'appelle ainsi parce que ce geste fait
partie du code de la route aux Pays-Bas.
Il consiste à ouvrir la portière, quand
on est conducteur, avec la main droite.
De cette manière, le conducteur est obligé
de se retourner, d'entrouvrir la portière
et là il vérifie qu'il n'y a personne.
Evidemment, s'il y a un cycliste,
on le laisse passer.
Côté vélo, les cyclistes doivent également
penser à s'équiper, à commencer par un
gilet réfléchissant.
Tenez, on va faire une petite expérience.
Il fait nuit, je suis sur une petite route
de campagne qui n'est pas éclairée, j'ai
mis mes feux de croisement.
Devant moi, je ne vois rien.
Pourtant, il y a bien un cycliste.
Gaspard ! Approche !
Seulement, sans gilet réfléchissant et sans
éclairage, on ne le voit pas.
Ben alors Gaspard, on fait du vélo sans gilet
réfléchissant et sans mettre la lumière ?
Allez, enfile ça !
L'éclairage, et maintenant, tu peux y aller !
Et là, on voit le cycliste de très, très
loin.
Jusqu'à 180 mètres, ce qui permet au conducteur
du véhicule d'anticiper.
Les feux de croisement d'une voiture n'éclairent
que jusqu'à une distance de 30 mètres.
Autrement dit, un cycliste qui ne porte pas
de gilet réfléchissant, n'est visible par
le conducteur qu'à cette distance.
Or, à 90 km/h, le véhicule la parcourt en
1 seconde.
Une seconde pour réagir et éviter le cycliste,
c'est peu.
Avec un gilet réfléchissant, comme ici,
et un bon éclairage, le cycliste est visible
à au moins 160 mètres, ce qui laisse le
temps au conducteur pour anticiper et dépasser
le vélo en toute sécurité.
Vous l'avez compris, il est essentiel pour
un cycliste d'être vu.
En plus du gilet réfléchissant, qui est
obligatoire la nuit hors agglomération, les
vélos doivent être équipés d'un éclairage
à l'avant et à l'arrière et de réflecteurs.
Après la vue, l'oreille.
La sonnette est elle aussi obligatoire tout
comme le casque pour les moins de 12 ans,
mais comme notre crâne est plutôt fragile,
il est également recommandé pour les adultes.
Les freins doivent être en bon état et les
cyclistes doivent respecter le code de la route.
Dernière chose : pas de téléphone ni d'oreillette !
Comme en voiture, ils perturbent l'attention.
La suite, eh bien, il faut simplement rester
en selle ! Allez, je vous dis à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo.